hey you just got said hello to by Josh
Lewis Holly black Cassie Claire and the
great Maureen Johnson as you can tell
from the great speckled walls behind me
I am currently in an airport actually
you're probably watching this in the
future in which case I'm hopefully not
currently in an airport unless you're
one of these people in which case you're
watching me in the present and I am
currently in an airport so I've been in
New York for the last couple days
meeting with my publisher Julie Strauss
gable and my agent Jody reamer to talk
about The Fault in Our Stars and all the
wonderful things that are happening none
of which I can tell you about do you
know what I do by the way when I am in
airports and my flood is delayed and I
have an hour to kill
I signed the Fault in Our Stars I
brought two thousand sheets to sign
today it's a green pen day in case
you're wondering I get excited about
like what the color day is I wake up in
one of the first thoughts I have is is
it a purple day I hope it's a purple day
but it's not it's always a green day
well that would be a good name for a
band Green Day so Hank because I spend
about six hours a day signing my name
over and over again I've been thinking a
lot about my signature and its many
insufficiencies I mean there's the
obvious problem of the complete
eligibility of my signature but another
disappointment about it is that it's
totally inconsistent like sometimes it
looks relatively good like this one and
then sometimes everyone's like this one
that are just you know tragically in a
revocable flawed and the weirdest part
that when I try to explain to Sarah
about these tragic and irrevocable flaws
and some of my signatures she thinks
that I'm crazy she says that's the exact
same signature as any other signature
but let me tell you when you spend six
hours a day looking at your signature
over and over and over again in 57,000
iterations you start to notice the
little things you know like the amount
of volume in the j scribble and whether
the hoover lee who lines up with the one
dirty wood in the J which is not even to
mention the variable length of the goo
but you go over here at the end of my
signature also this who's anyone up here
sometimes I don't even write that
because my hand goes off the paper it's
a disaster Hank I just had one of those
the people at the airport think that I'm
crazy moments and it occurred to me that
you probably also think that I'm crazy I
hope that I'm not suffering from signing
madness that's a disease you know I made
it up but it's a disease hey let's go
see if there's anything interesting in
the airport look at all the free iPads
that's interesting pizza is interesting
a monument to dead
is kinda interesting right to a funny
story by the way John from the future
here I'm in a different airport but
anyway right after I said that thing
about how it's sort of interesting to
see a monument to a dead sheep a police
officer walked up to me and he said what
are you doing and I said I'm filming a
monument to a deceased sheep and he said
why are you doing that and I said it's a
really really long story and then he
just looked at me for a while and
finally I said is it illegal and he said
I don't know and so I was like well as
long as we're in this legal gray area
can I keep doing it and he said you
probably shouldn't so thus ends the vlog
I have to go get on a different airplane
because the previous airplane wasn't fun
enough but Hank I will see you on Friday
unless it is Friday in which case I will
see you on Monday sorry I don't have my
calendar with me hi it's John from the
future future I made it back home so
that's good quick PS in the great
tradition of older brothers I have taken
a cool toy that my little brother
enjoyed playing with and stolen it I'm
referring of course to the YouTube
channel Hank games I've started a series
of videos in which I play fifa while
telling you stories of my life so for
instance if you click on my face right
now you will be taken to a video where I
am playing as the Swindon Town swooty
poopers while simultaneously telling you
about how I met and courted the Yeti so
you can check that out there and if you
liked subscribe and thank hey look it's
my calendar I missed your calendar